[Applause]
you are about to enjoy a free preview
from the disney and pixar film turning
red now available
[Music]
you ready
let's do this
oh
our family runs one of the oldest
temples in toronto and the most unique
instead of honoring a god we honor our
ancestors and not just the dudes either
our most revered ancestor sunny was a
scholar poet and defender of animals she
dedicated her life to the creatures of
the forest especially the red panda
which she loved for her fiery
ever since the red panda has blessed our
family with good fortune and prosperity
and it can bless yours too
[Music]
bye-bye see you next time thanks for
coming
give me five oh yeah come on dad's
making dinner
[Music]
um
[Music]
hi you should have listened to his
mother and married ling yi totally
so two-faced she's just using him to get
to the throne
she'll probably stab him on their
wedding night mm-hmm
hmm
perfect yes
and now you get to experience them live
so worldwide boxing station four towns
we'll be kicking off their north
american tour tickets on sale now
oh my gosh who are these hip-hoppers and
why are they called four-town if there
are five of them uh
i don't know
some of the kids at school like them you
mean miriam that girl is
odd
dinner's ready
[Music]
um
[Music]
kind of looks like
seven
i don't get what mir sees in him he's
not that cute
okay his shoulder's like kind of nice
i guess
his eyes are
fine
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
laughs
[Music]
do you want a snack cool great thanks
don't look at the notebook don't look at
the notebook don't
no
oh
is this your homeroom oh
oh my what you put together
what mom
oh maybe what is this it's nothing just
the boy he's not no boy
who is he did he do these things to you
no
it's just made up mom
it's not real
that hat
is that the sketchy clerk from the daisy
moss mom no
what are you doing
no no no no no no no no no no no
it's not
mom no
you oh what have you done to my maymay
uh who maylen lee right here
i should report you to the police
how old are you 30. i'm 17. see see this
is what happens when you don't wear
sunblock and do drugs all day she's just
a sweet innocent child how dare you take
advantage of her mom
what
[Music]
the daisy mart has lost a loyal customer
today
[Laughter]
thank goodness i was here that
degenerate won't come near you again
now
is there anything else i should know
about maymay
nope
all good
[Music]
you sicko what were you thinking why
would you draw those things those
horrible awful sexy things it's fine
you'll move to another city and change
your identity
[Music]
mommy
i'm so sorry
you are her pride and joy so act like it
this will never
happen again
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
oh
no sugar
coming
porridge
see what happens next order the entire
movie disney and pixar's turning red now
available rated pg